- When you're a brand,
I think that a lot of
people are starting to
finally have the right
conversation, which is like cool,
I got eight trillion,
gadrillion impressions
and like did I really sell more
body spray because of it, right?
Look, the more that we can be a beacon to
conversations around
actual business results
and not reporting headlines and awards,
we will end up being historically correct.
And that being said, I
think the best way to
get those results is to make branding and
marketing content not dr content.
♪ You thought you were perfect, so did I ♪
♪ Ain't nobody perfect, who am I? ♪
♪ I'm a good person, open fire. ♪
♪ Prratt, prratt, tell the boss
yeah, they won't survive. ♪
♪ You thought you were
perfect, so did I. ♪
♪ Ain't nobody perfect, who am I? ♪
- Alright, let's do it.
♪ I'm a good person, open fire. ♪
♪ Prratt, prratt, tell the boss yeah, ♪
♪ That ain't working on me, aye, ♪
♪ That ain't working on me,
I've been working on me. ♪
- I don't, I'm a
sabotager, this is exactly
what you're not supposed to do.
(group laughing)
No, really, I can feel
me doing the wrong thing.
- I love you dropping knowledge,
but I also wanna...It
took us awhile to get over
what you just said,
- Yes
- and come up with different stuff.
- Yes. I know.
- So, keep it to your group.
- Respect. (laughing) Ben
listen to this real quick,
I'm gonna text you an idea. (laughing)
♪ I've been working on me. ♪
♪ Aye,I've been working on me. ♪
♪ Aye, that ain't working on me. ♪
♪ Aye, that ain't working on me, ♪
♪ Aye, I've been working on me ♪
♪ I've been working on me, yeah. ♪
♪ I think we got off on the wrong foot. ♪
- Joyce will make the blog too, vlog.
I feel it, I feel the next ...
I feel like when force shit, like when
we forced, we're gonna get better at
Youtube come this September, forced.
I feel in the last three days,
I'm ready to break some
patterns, and it feels great.
I can feel it, we have
the meeting on Friday
with the whole team, I'm like yo,
good morning all of
you, shit's coming down.
And I think that's why I did it.
And I think that having
fun with your audience
and doing something nice
is a tremendous formula.
♪ So did I, ain't nobody
perfect, who am I? ♪
♪ I'm a good person, open
fire, prratt, prratt ♪
♪ Tell the boss yeah, that
ain't working on me. ♪
♪ Aye, that ain't working on me. ♪
♪ Aye, I've been working on me. ♪
♪ I've been working on me, yeah. ♪
♪ You ain't 'bout to hit
me with them mind games. ♪
- Gary.
- Ryan.
- How are you? Ryan,
such a pleasure, welcome.
- Pleasure. Nice to meet you Gary.
- Such a pleasure, how are you?
- Good, how are you?
- Very good.
- So Masterminds, you're
never going to do them?
- I'm not.
- And what's your opinion for
those going to these...Do
they fact check them?
- Look if people get
value, they get value.
Listen, I don't think I deserve
to judge anybody about anything.
I spit my truth and then everybody
decides what they decide.
I don't think that I'm
better than anybody.
I don't think that I am
right, I really don't.
I buy 150 dollar...I bought this.
How much did this cost me, a buck fifty?
I bought a hundred
fifty dollar Jets jersey
that has Ichiro Suzuki's name on it
cuz he made fun of Tom Brady.
I would argue that that's a stupid
use of a hundred fifty dollars
but it means something to me, and so
I don't have any interest in judging.
If somebody pays some guy or gal
Fifty thousand dollars a year to
be in their Mastermind and they
think that's valuable, cool.
I just think we're in
a very interesting time
where there's unbelievably
meaningful content
for free, at scale, and that's
something worth debating.
- Yeah.
- I can't get that for free.
- Yep.
- I think a lot of stuff that I heard
in these Mastermind's,
look, I'm unbelievably
typically cynical about somebody who's
never made money in any other way
than telling people how to make money.
♪ No talk, no sound ♪
♪ Used to answer every
text, but I don't now. ♪
- You're the people
caught up in your deal.
- Always.
- You're the one that loses.
♪ Honestly I'm better on my own now. ♪
♪ Always on that gram and my phone ♪
♪ Used to show your page super
crazy love, but I don't now. ♪
♪ You thought you were
perfect, so did I. ♪
♪ Ain't nobody perfect, who am I. ♪
♪ I'm a good person, open fire. ♪
♪ Prratt, prratt, tell the
boss, yeah, he won't survive. ♪
♪ You thought you were
perfect, so did I. ♪
♪ Ain't nobody perfect, who am I. ♪
♪ I'm a good person open fire. ♪
♪ Prratt, prratt, tell the boss, ♪
♪ Yeah, that ain't working on me. ♪
♪ Aye, that ain't working on me. ♪
♪ Aye, I've been working on me. ♪
- I can't believe we pulled that off.
- I can't either.
- Mark!
You're the best Mark!
Did you kiss Mark's face?
- I didn't know I should.
- Go kiss it.
(laughing)
This is from Brandon Warnecki,
my best friend in the human world.
- Okay.
- At 8:04 AM Sunday morning.
This is to me and Tyler.
I know this sounds crazy
but ever since my kids
discovered the backpack kid, they are
hooked on Gary's videos with him,
and now Gary's content in general.
But because of the language,
I don't want them to watch.
This morning, Erin his daughter,
went into a tantrum because
she couldn't watch Gary.
Life is insane, there should be
an edited version for kid hustlers.
Tyler replies, we have
censored a ton of it.
Brandon's like, really,
awesome, would love it.
Bottom line is, I just wanted
you to know that, it's funny.
I want to launch my YouTube kids channel.
- Wait so we had everyone
go see a Knick game, right?
And you're sitting at my table watching
a cartoon on Tv, and you and I had a call.
- Timeout, one more time, we ...
- Shawn was in the office, you
were on the phone somewhere.
It was like me, you, somebody
else, we were on a call.
Shawn's in the office,
you have no idea, right?
But I had you on speaker phone.
It was before we went to a
Knick game with them, right?
And all of a sudden you
went on one of your rants.
Like, fuck that, I'll kick his ass.
Fuck do he think he is, think he's gonna
crush me and I'll fucking crush him.
And all of a sudden Shawn's
face just goes like this
and he turns around, he's
like Gary likes the f word.
(laughing)
- Because the longer you can continue
to just purely bring the audience value
you're putting things in the bank.
I hate when I have a new
book or a sneaker out.
It means I'm taking out of the bank.
You ask, you can say
whatever you want about
authenticity and this and that.
There's asking and there's
giving, my preference is giving
Attention is the equity, it's the asset.